hey Luke here with the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and I'm restoring this
ax this thing is a monster it weighs a
little over eight pounds it's hand
forged and it's gonna be awesome
[Music]
well guys I really think you're gonna
like this project this is an 8-pound
hewing axe it's from a time and an era
when men hand hewed their logs into
lumber and it's unusual to find
something this old with so few problems
got very little damage on it this thing
is in great shape there's a pitting mark
right there I'm not sure what that's
from looks like might have been a
manufacturing defect and they forged it
got this cut and they've got some dings
along here not sure what caused that but
that looks like some metal on metal then
right here we've got mushrooming on the
edge there's some writing right here a
little maker's mark of some sort that I
cannot make it out cannot read it a
little bit of mushrooming along the edge
it actually looks pretty nice the other
side looks great very minor scuffs a
little bit of flaking right there you
can tell this is hand forged because the
hole is not symmetrical it's flat on one
side and concave on the other that's how
you forged a blade like this they they
kind of make it two-dimensional and then
they fold it over 90 degrees here than
90 degrees there and then Forge weld it
along this edge and that's how they
created it the seam where they forged
well there's no cracks or anything so
that's a good sign
all right well it's time to get started
I'm gonna first hit this the 40 grit
flapper desk and really try to shape it
and get rid of all the pits and grooves
[Music]
[Music]
well three and a half hours of grinding
later I am absolutely covered in metal
shavings but look at this I got one side
roughed out only burned up 640 grit
flapper disks this is going to look
really awesome
[Music]
well I've got a big pile of burned up
flapper disks I've got myself one shiny
broadhead axe now I gotta do is just hit
it with the finer grits and start
polishing well guys it's been a few
months since I worked on this project in
the middle of filming my family I went
to Alaska and then when we came back I
made an african spear did some fishing
videos and before you know it it's
December and you can see here that I
picked up some rough spots on on the axe
here because I was just roughly grinding
it you know I was using a pretty coarse
flapper wheel and that exposes it to
rust the finer you polish it the more
rust resistant is and with a non
stainless steel like this you've got to
have it polished and you got to keep it
oiled or it picks up rough spots so I've
gotta go and knock the rust spots off
this and pick up where I left off
[Music]
well that rust came off really easy so
I'm just gonna go ahead and switch out
from a 40 grit flapper wheel and I'm
gonna put on the 120 grit flapper wheel
and we're gonna go from there
[Music]
there we go I've hit it with the 120 and
really all you're doing with the 120
grit is you're just trying to take out
the marks from the 40 grit you shouldn't
be really working on getting out
imperfections with the 120 now we got to
try to polish it up now what you're
doing is if you can look in here it
looks pretty shiny but you can see all
these lines those little swirly marks
from the angle grinder so what we're
trying to do is get those out that's all
we're really doing we're not getting rid
of these imperfections that the 48 grit
didn't get out we're just trying to get
the tooling marks from the angle grinder
removed I've got this little buffing
wheel here the different grits buffing
chalk I can't remember which ones which
I think the white ones the coarsest
[Music]
all right there we go looking pretty
shiny it's not a perfect mirror finish
but it's looking pretty nice there's
definitely some imperfection in it but
you know it lets you know that it's old
so I've got this piece of African
mahogany that's left over from my
African sphere project it's just the
right thickness and gosh darn it it's a
beautiful piece of wood so I'm gonna
make the handle out of this now I'm
really thinking about redoing my African
spear project so I'm going to cut a
strip like this right off that's gonna
be the shaft for my second spear then
this is gonna be the handle well there
we go a beautiful piece of African
mahogany that's just waiting to become
an axe handle so I'm gonna shape the
head fit it to the blade first then
we're gonna do the handle okay
[Music]
there we go doesn't that look nice real
nice smooth fit a little bit of contact
right here which gives a little extra
strength so if you hit down low it
doesn't put as much torque on the the
thin part now I just need to go and make
this part pretty and then shape the
handle so I've got this replacement
handle right here and look at that it's
almost exact
[Music]
let's check this out oh well this feels
like a pretty good stopping point I'm
losing my sunlight I am tired and I have
got a lot of things to do all right so
what I need to do next is round out the
handle make it a little bit more
ergonomic clean up the connection
between the blade and the wood sand it
polish it and then mount it
[Music]
[Music]
we got the handle shape the way I like
it
good-looking handles now I need to sand
it first with the 80 grit to take away
these edges and then I've got to start
polishing it so I'll go 80 grit
120 grit 400 grit 800 grit thousand grit
1,500 or 2,000 grit might even have some
6,000 grit in here somewhere and by the
time I've done this thing is going to be
bu T fault
[Music]
now typically I'd be using linseed oil
but I don't have any so I'm using
mineral oils which is basically wd-40
look at that isn't that gorgeous it's
nothing but sanding a little bit of oil
and it is absolutely beautiful
Nathan you like that is that cool now
it's time for me to cut a slit right
down the middle right right down here
and this is the part that makes me more
nervous than any other step because if
I'm off just a little to one side or
it's crooked it'll make it weak and
it'll make a really good chance that
this breaks off now I want it to be dead
center so I'm gonna go put this in the
bench vise but it's dark out and I'm not
sure how good the videos gonna look so
let's see what happens there we go all
right let's see if it fits
Oh like a glove okay looking good all
right all I gotta do is make a wedge
from this scrap piece of African
mahogany and then we can mount the X
[Music]
there we go I got the wedge done it is
super thin because there is not a lot of
play in this part of the axe handle so I
can't expand it very much and I want to
get that wedge down in there deep so
it's got to be a very thin wedge this
might actually be too thick
yep we let that wedge sit in there let
the glue dry and then we're gonna trim
it up oh ho
looks good Oh dry there you go
there is the finished product look at
that that is gorgeous
so I'm sure a lot of you guys noticed
that unlike my other videos I didn't
sharpen this axe at all the reason for
that is it's already really sharp this
is an eight pound axe I mean this thing
is more like a splitting maul and less
like a barber's razor so putting a
really fine edge on it is kind of
pointless because it'll just get
destroyed from the force of of wielding
such a big heavy piece of metal so I
think it's pretty darn sharp considering
what it's used for already also I get a
lot of people asking why I don't temper
these blades that I restore why don't I
put them in the four jandry temper him
there shouldn't be any need for that
there's I have no reason to suspect the
tempers been monkeyed with plus I really
don't know what kind of steel this is
and if you don't know what kind of steel
you're dealing with tempering can be
really dodgy because each type of steel
needs to be tempered a specific way if
you don't know what you're doing just
leave it alone now I'm not an expert on
these things but I believe this type of
axe is called a human axe it's flat on
one side and round on the other and the
purpose of that is so that you can make
round logs into square logs so well when
carpenters were taking trees and turning
them into lumber for building houses
they wanted to make them square right
and so the flat side is the side that
you want to make flat it allows you to
get a straighter edge with this blade
I'm gonna try to do this without putting
the blade into my right leg I cannot
make any promises that won't happen now
I've seen guys do this before and they
did it while standing on the log which
seemed really impressive
so what I believe that guys would do is
they'd stand on the logs and they would
hew the right side until it's all flat
then they would rotate the log 90
degrees and do it again and do it again
do it again
always cueing on the right side of the
log well there you go roughly hewed out
this one side of the log not that easy
it takes a bit of skill and props to
anybody who can do this really well
especially without cutting your feet off
well guys I hope you enjoyed this video
if you'd like to see more great videos
from the outdoor boys youtube channel
don't forget to